the first of two women accusing Virginia
of lieutenant-governor of sexual assault
says it is her civic duty to come
forward
Vanessa Tyson is her name she says that
lieutenant governor Justin Fairfax
assaulted her in 2004 now he
categorically denies these allegations
when Tyson and Meredith Watson first
told their stories Fairfax compared
himself to victims of lynching Tyson
responded to his claim in an interview
you'll see only on CBS this morning
what do you make of just in Fairfax
comparing himself to a lynching victim
never was it to black women lynching
black men one need only look at history
to try to understand that in fact that
the role of black women had always been
to you know leading anti lynching
campaigns you know black women were
lynched specifically trying to protect
black men and speaking as someone who
teaches black politics I find it
disgraceful irresponsible and
manipulative is this a racial issue to
you sexual assault
should never be a racial issue it should
never be a partisan issue the sexual
assault is an epidemic that's taking
place around the world across our
country every day what do you want to
happen to just in Fairfax why are you
coming forward I'd want him to resign I
think the Virginia people the voters of
Virginia have a right to know you know
both my story and Meredith's story he
said this is an orchestrated smear
campaign against him yes by you and
Meredith Watson I've never met Meredith
Watson I don't know what she looks like
I've never spoken with her she also says
she has never met you and never spoken
to you either and when I talked to her
she really fell apart when she said she
feels tremendous guilt that she didn't
come forward because it happened to her
she says in 2000 she can never blame
herself this wasn't her it wasn't me
it wasn't either
one of us it was Justin Fairfax one
thing I will say is that it's hard it I
can't even begin to tell you how hard it
is it it is to come forward especially
against someone powerful and when she
came forward she didn't want me to feel
alone and that meant the world to me
because it's it's just hard to be alone
Meredith Watson came forward shortly
after Vanessa Tyson made her accusations
in February she told us that she's very
sorry for not reporting her allegation
that fairfax raped her nearly 20 years
ago why do you feel guilty
Fairfax maintains that both women are
making false accusations in a statement
to CBS News the Lieutenant Governor said
this to us
I am able to hear the pain they have
expressed a pain I hope they are able to
resolve and heal however because I never
assaulted either dr. Tyson or miss
Watson I know that my actions cannot be
the source of that pain now you can find
the lieutenant governor's full statement
on our website that CBS s Morning Calm
we are hoping that lieutenant governor
Fairfax will speak to us at some point
you will see more of our interview with
Meredith Watson tomorrow including why
she's asking for a public hearing as
opposed to an investigation and that she
is ready to testify under oath they both
say that they want to testify under oath
and they both women say about consensual
because Justin Fairfax who says that
these were consensual acts and both of
them say can't be consensual if they
felt that they were forced I said there
was a very distinct difference there and
there's an incredible amount of pain
there yes I feel a turn all these years
later
that pain has stuck with them about how
they felt in that moment and how it has
affected them now for decades you know
and think about the learning we have
done there was a period half a year ago
where people said you know these people
are coming forward after so many years
why how why are they coming forward how
can it really be so real and we have now
seen example after example of how it is
as real as if it happened yesterday
right John mm-hmm